Matt LeBlanc my blog it presumably
hosting Top Gear is like your dream job
yeah it's kind of like this it's a lot
bigger than I thought it was you know
when I when I first did the show was fun
and then now being a part of it I mean
it is it just a international juggernaut
of a show it's pretty cold innit 170
territories or countries or something I
don't yes sir premieres this Sunday and
by Wednesday it'll be in 83 countries on
six continents already by Wednesday
Wow that's it's just huge and how did
this happen did you call them did they
call you did you bump into someone a
lift how does it happen well I did it
the first time to promote episodes who
did the around the track in the car and
that went pretty good well you were the
fastest ever aren't you oh yeah and then
I went they got a new car and I went
back to do it in the new car so if I
could beat the old record and then they
did this thing called Top Gear the races
which was kind of like a greatest hits
of Top Gear and I kind of introduced the
clips shot these little video wrap
arounds and that went good and then
Chris was already on board at that point
and they approached me and asked if I
would like to be a part of it and then
Alex rent and the producer flew to LA we
had a meeting and kind of told me what
the idea was for the new shape of it it
sounded cool and I wasn't doing anything
else it's been a lot of fun Chris and I
get along good it's really fun yeah and
you are a proper petrol head I mean you
do love cars and engines and all that
stuff yeah you know it's funny like I
I'm one of those people I subscribed to
like about 15 different car magazines
you go to my house on the coffee table
just stacked up with forever I've been
doing that and someone just said to me
that they finally it's paying off okay
you knew we were preparing for this job
your whole life and the first episode
part of it is a kind of Britain versus
America challenge yes that's right yeah
so what's the challenge okay it's so do
you know the Reliant Robin and that call
you okay yeah they are yeah well these
are reliant rial tows the upgraded one
which
the changes still I've never heard of a
rialto anyone Reliant Robin you first
yeah Roberts yeah a famous by Only Fools
and Horses yeah wasn't it yeah he'd a
little Vande and he know we had one one
of those didn't eat but it was a van
back of amber what do they have are
they've got no career oh they've cut the
roofs off nice because it's gonna be
raining so they figured better to have
no roof yes so we have to drive from
London to Blackpool in those nice Hey
mine broke down about 10 times worsen
and I think Chris had it fixed because
it's USA versus the UK and we're in
English cars his is painted like the
Union Jack mine stars of stretch and
mine breaks down repeatedly his ran like
a clock go figure
long ever been to Blackpool before no he
had golden half of our favourite
churning uh he might
it was you know we actually had a really
good time it was um weather-wise wasn't
the sunniest day but the whole town like
got involved and the thing was it was
actually we had a really good time and
then he went back to my neck of the
woods you were in Southern Ireland West
Cork and Harry ring of kerry yeah Dingle
and Killarney and all that we did a
thing with the Rolls Royce over there
where I was really fun
Wow and that was this woman was she just
take your picture and you literally
drove by she was with her girlfriend and
they were on their way to the her hen do
you call it like a hen dude that's what
we call in the States and we were
driving up the road it was me in the new
rolls-royce dawn the convertible and
Chris Evans was in his rolls-royce
Corniche from 76 and there was a
comparison old and new and we'd kind of
at a red light and I think was in Dingle
they were walking there and they come
over and they just took a selfie she put
it on Twitter or something social media
whatever it was you know genuinely happy
isn't she had a very short skirt
suspiciously happy more of a bell please
go ahead and do it was her head
a pet oh no no no no yes yes so there's
this summer suppose that maybe they're
like no it was great but you're sort of
not really on very much are you